The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Let's start.
So last time, we started
with kinetic theory.
And we will focus for
gas systems mostly.
And the question
that we would like
to think about and answer
somehow is the following.
You start with a gas
that is initially
confined to one chamber.
And you can calculate all of
its thermodynamic properties.
You open at time 0 a
hole, allowing the gas
to escape into a second
initially empty chamber.
And after some time,
the whole system
will come to a new
equilibrium position.
It's a pretty reversible thing.
You can do this experiment
many, many times.
And you will always get
roughly the same amount of time
for the situation to
start from one equilibrium
and reach another equilibrium.
So how do we describe that?
It's slightly beyond what
we did in thermodynamics,
because we want to go
from one equilibrium state
to another equilibrium state.
Now, we said, OK, we know
the equations of motion
that governs the particles
that are described by this.
So here we can say that we
have, let's say, N particles.
They have their own
momenta and coordinates.
And we know that these
momenta and coordinates evolve
in time, governed
by some Hamiltonian,
which is a function of all of
these momenta and coordinates.
OK?
Fine.
How do we go from
a situation which
describes a whole
bunch of things
and coordinates that
are changing with time
to some microscopic description
of macroscopic variables going
from one equilibrium
state to another?
So our first attempt
in that direction
was to say, well, I could start
with many, many, many examples
of the same situation.
Each one of them would
correspond to a different
trajectory of p's and q's.
And so what we can
do is to construct
some kind of an ensemble
average, or ensemble density,
first, which is what we did.
We can say that the very, very
many examples of this situation
that I can have will
correspond to different points
at some particular
instant of time,
occupying this
6N-dimensional phase space,
out of which I can construct
some kind of a density in phase
space.
But then I realize that since
each one of these trajectories
is evolving according
to this Hamiltonian,
this density could potentially
be a function of time.
And we described the
equation for the evolution
of that density with time.
And we could write it in
this form-- V rho by dt
is the Poisson bracket of
the Hamiltonian with rho.
And this Poisson
bracket was defined
as a sum over all
of your coordinates.
Oops.
We had d rho by d vector qi,
dot product with dH by dpi minus
the other [? way. ?]
So there are essentially
three N terms-- well,
actually, six N terms, but three
N pairs of terms in this sum.
I can either use
some index alpha
running from one to
three N, or indicate them
as contributions of things that
come from individual particles
and then use this notation
with three vectors.
So this is essentially
a combination
of sum of three terms.
OK?
So I hope that
somehow this equation
can describe the evolution
that goes on over here.
And ultimately, when I wait
sufficiently long time,
I will reach a situation
where d rho by dt
does not change anymore.
And I will find some density
that is invariant on time.
I'll call that rho equilibrium.
And so we saw that we could have
our rho equilibrium, which then
should have zero Poisson bracket
with H to be a function of H
and any other
conserved quantity.
OK?
So in principle,
we sort of thought
of a way of describing
how the system will evolve
in equilibrium--
towards an equilibrium.
And indeed, we will find that in
statistical mechanics later on,
we are going to rely heavily
on these descriptions
of equilibrium
densities, which are
governed by only
the Hamiltonian.
And if there are any other
conserved quantities,
typically there are not.
So this is the general
form that we'll ultimately
be using a lot.
But we started
with a description
of evolution of
these coordinates
in time, which is
time-reversible.
And we hope to end up
with a situation that
is analogous to what we
describe thermodynamically,
we describe something that
goes to some particular state,
and basically
stays there, as far
as the macroscopic
description is concerned.
So did we somehow manage to just
look at something else, which
is this density, and
achieve this transition
from reversibility
to irreversibility?
And the answer is no.
This equation-- also,
if you find, indeed,
a rho that goes from here to
here, you can set t to minus t
and get a rho that goes
from back here to here.
It has the same
time-reversibility.
So somehow, we have to
find another solution.
And the solution that we
will gradually build upon
relies more on
physics rather than
the rigorous mathematical
nature of this thing.
Physically, we know
that this happens.
All of us have seen this.
So somehow, we should be able
to use physical approximation
and assumptions that
are compatible with what
is observed.
And if, during that,
we have to sort of make
mathematical
approximations, so be it.
In fact, we have to make
mathematical approximations,
because otherwise, there is
this very strong reversibility
condition.
So let's see how we are about
to proceed, thinking more
in terms of physics.
Now, the information
that I have over here,
either in this
description of ensemble
or in this description
in terms of trajectories,
is just enormous.
I can't think of any
physical process which
would need to keep track of the
joined positions of coordinates
and momenta of 10
to the 23 particles,
and know them with infinite
precision, et cetera.
Things that I make
observations with
and I say, we see this,
well, what do we see?
We see that something has some
kind of a density over here.
It has some kind of pressure.
Maybe there is, in the
middle of this process,
some flow of gas particles.
We can talk about the
velocity of those things.
And let's say even
when we are sort
of being very non-equilibrium
and thinking about velocity
of those particles going from
one side to the other side,
we really don't care which
particle among the 10 to the 23
is at some instant
of time contributing
to the velocity of the
gas that is swishing past.
So clearly, any physical
observable that we make
is something that
does not require
all of those degrees of freedom.
So let's just construct
some of those things
that we may find
useful and see how
we would describe
evolutions of them.
I mean, the most useful
thing, indeed, is the density.
So what I could do
is I can actually
construct a
one-particle density.
So I want to look at
some position in space
at some time t and
ask whether or not
there are particles there.
I don't care which
one of the particles.
Actually, let's put in a
little bit more information;
also, keep track of whether,
at some instant of time,
I see at this
location particles.
And these particles,
I will also ask
which direction they are moving.
Maybe I'm also going
to think about the case
where, in the intermediate,
I am flowing from one side
to another.
And keeping track of both
of these is important.
I said I don't care which
one of these particles
is contributing.
So that means that I have
to sum over all particles
and ask whether
or not, at time t,
there is a particle at
location q with momentum p.
So these delta functions are
supposed to enforce that.
And again, I'm not thinking
about an individual trajectory,
because I think, more or
less, all of the trajectories
are going to behave
the same way.
And so what I will do
is I take an ensemble
average of this quantity.
OK?
So what does that mean?
To do an ensemble
average, we said
I have to integrate the
density function, rho,
which depends on all
of the coordinates.
So I have coordinate
for particle one,
coordinate-- particle and
momentum, particle and momentum
for particle two,
for particle three,
all the way to
particle number N.
And this is something
that depends on time.
That's where the time
dependence comes from.
And again, let's think
about the time dependence
where 0 is you
lift the partition
and you allow things to
go from one to the other.
So there is a non-equilibrium
process that you are following.
What I need to do is I have
to multiply this density
with the function that I
have to consider the average.
Well, the function being a
delta function, it's very nice.
The first term in the sum,
we'll set simply q1 equals to q.
And it will set p1
equals to p when
I do the integration
over p1 and q1.
But then I'm left to have to do
the integration over particle
two, particle three,
particle four, and so forth.
OK?
But this is only the
first term in the sum.
Then I have to write the
sum for particle number two,
particle number
three, et cetera.
But all of the particles,
as far as I'm concerned,
are behaving the same way.
So I just need to multiply
this by a factor of N.
Now, this is something that
actually we encountered before.
Recall that this rho is a
joint probability distribution.
It's a joint
probability distribution
of all N particles, their
locations, and momentum.
And we gave a name to taking
a joint probability density
function, which this
is, and integrating
over some subset of variables.
The answer is an unconditional
probability distribution.
So essentially, the
end of this story
is if I integrate
over coordinates
of two all the way to N, I will
get an unconditional result
pertaining to the first
set of coordinate.
So this is the same thing
up to a factor of N--
the unconditional probability
that I will call rho one.
Actually, I should
have called this f1.
So this is something
that is defined
to be the one particle density.
I don't know why this name stuck
to it, because this one, that
is up to a factor of
N different from it,
is our usual unconditional
probability for one particle.
So this is rho of p1 being
p, q1 being q at time.
OK?
So essentially, what I've said
is I have a joint probability.
I'm really interested
in one of the particles,
so I just integrate
over all the others.
And this is kind of
not very elegant,
but that's somehow
the way that it
has appeared in the literature.
The entity that I
have on the right
is the properly
normalized probability.
Once I multiply by N, it's a
quantity this is called f1.
And it's called a density
and used very much
in the literature.
OK?
And that's the thing that
I think will be useful.
Essentially, all of
the things that I
know about observations
of a system,
such as its density,
its velocity, et cetera,
I should be able
to get from this.
Sometimes we need a little
bit more information,
so I allow for the
possibility that I may also
need to focus on a
two-particle density, where
I keep information pertaining
to two particles at time t
and I integrate over everybody
else that I'm not interested.
So I introduce an integration
over coordinates number
two-- sorry, number
three all the way to N
to not have to repeat this
combination all the time.
The 6N-dimensional
phase space for particle
i I will indicate by dVi.
So I take the full N particle
density, if you like,
integrate over
everybody except 2.
And up to a normalization
of NN minus 1,
this is called a
two-particle density.
And again, absent
this normalization,
this is simply the
unconditional probability
that I would construct out
of this joint probability
[INAUDIBLE].
And just for some mathematical
purposes, the generalization
of this to S particles,
we will call fs.
So this depends on p1
through qs at time t.
And this is going to
be N factorial divided
by N minus S
factorial in general.
And they join the unconditional
probability that depends on S
coordinates p1
through qs at time t.
OK?
You'll see why I need
these higher ones
although, in reality, all my
interest is on this first one,
because practically
everything that I need
to know about this initial
experiment that I set up
and how a gas expands I
should be able to extract
from this one-particle density.
OK?
So how do I calculate this?
Well, what I would
need to do is to look
at the time variation
of fs with t
to calculate the time dependence
of any one of these quantities.
Ultimately, I want to have
an equation for df1 by dt.
But let's write the general one.
So the general one is up
to, again, this N factorial,
N minus s factorial
and integral over
coordinates that I'm not
interested, of d rho by dt.
OK?
So I just take the time
derivative inside the integral,
because I know how
d rho by dt evolves.
And so this is going to be
simply the Poisson bracket of H
and rho.
And I would proceed from there.
Actually, to proceed
further and in order
to be able to say things
that are related to physics,
I need to say something
about the Hamiltonian.
I can't do so in the
most general case.
So let's write the
kind of Hamiltonian
that we are interested
and describes the gas-- so
the Hamiltonian for
the gas in this room.
One term is simply
the kinetic energy.
Another term is
that gas particles
are confined by some potential.
The potential could be as easy
as the walls of this room.
Or it could be some
more general potential
that could include gravity,
whatever else you want.
So let's include
that possibility.
So these are so-called
one-body terms,
because they pertain to the
coordinates of one particle.
And then there are
two-body terms.
So for example, I could look
at all pairs of particles.
Let's say i not equal to j
to avoid self-interaction.
V of qi minus qj.
So certainly, two particles
in this gas in this room,
when they get close
enough, they certainly
can pass through each other.
They each have a size.
But even when they are
a few times their sizes,
they start to feel
some interaction, which
causes them to collide.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The whole
series of arguments
that we're developing,
do these only hold
for time-independent potentials?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Although, it is not that
difficult to sort of
go through all of
these arguments
and see where the corresponding
modifications are going to be.
But certainly, the
very first thing
that we are using, which is
this one, we kind of implicitly
assume the time-independent
Hamiltonian.
So you have to start changing
things from that point.
OK?
So in principle, you could
have three-body and higher body
terms.
But essentially, most
of the relevant physics
is captured by this.
Even for things
like plasmas, this
would be a reasonably
good approximation,
with the Coulomb
interaction appearing here.
OK?
Now, what I note is that what
I have to calculate over here
is a Poisson bracket.
And then I have to integrate
that Poisson bracket.
Poisson bracket
involves a whole bunch
of derivatives over
all set of quantities.
And I realize that when I'm
integrating over derivatives,
there are
simplifications that can
take place, such as
integration by parts.
But that only will take
place when the derivative
is one of the variables
that is being integrated.
Now, this whole process has
separated out arguments of rho,
as far as this
expression is concerned,
into two sets-- one set, or the
set that is appearing out here,
the first s ones that don't
undergo the integration,
and then the remainder that
do undergo the integration.
So this is going to be relevant
when we do our manipulations.
And therefore, it is useful
to rewrite this Hamiltonian
in terms of three entities.
The first one that I call
H sub s-- so if you like,
this is an end
particle Hamiltonian.
I can write an H sub s, which
is just exactly the same thing,
except that it
applies to coordinates
that I'm not integrating over.
And to sort of
make a distinction,
I will label them by N. And
it includes the interaction
among those particles.
And I can similarly
write something
that pertains to coordinates
that I am integrating over.
I will label them by j and k.
So this is s plus 1 to N, pj
squared over 2m plus u of qj
plus 1/2 sum over j and
k, V of qj minus qk.
OK?
So everything that involves one
set of coordinates, everything
that involves the other
set of coordinates.
So what is left are terms
that [? copy ?] one set of
coordinates to another.
So N running from 1 to s,
j running from s plus 1
to N, V between qm and qj.
OK?
So let me rewrite this
equation rather than in terms
of-- f in terms of the
probabilities' rhos.
So the difference
only is that I don't
have to include this
factor out front.
So I have dVi.
I have the d rho by dt, which
is the commutator of H with rho,
which I have been writing
as Hs plus HN minus s.
I'm changing the way I write s.
Sorry.
Plus H prime and rho.
OK?
So there is a bit
of mathematics to be
performed to analyze this.
There are three terms
that I will label a, b,
and c, which are
the three Poisson
brackets that I
have to evaluate.
So the contribution
that I call a
is the integral
over coordinates s
plus 1 to N, of the Poisson
bracket of Hs with rho.
Now, the Poisson bracket
is given up here.
It is a sum that involves N
terms over all N particles.
But since, if I'm
evaluating it for Hs and Hs
will only give nonzero
derivatives with respect
to the coordinates
that are present in it,
this sum of N terms
actually becomes simply
a sum of small N terms.
So I will get a sum over
N running from 1 to s.
These are the only terms.
And I will get the things that
I have for d rho by dpN-- sorry,
rho by dqN, dHs by dpN minus
d rho by dpN, dHs by dqN.
OK?
Did I make a mistake?
AUDIENCE: Isn't it the Poisson
bracket of rho H, not H rho?
PROFESSOR: Rho.
Oh, yes.
So I have to put
a minus sign here.
Right.
Good.
Thank you.
OK.
Now, note that these
derivatives and operations that
involve Hs involve
coordinates that are not
appearing in the
integration process.
So I can take
these entities that
do not depend on
variables that are part
of the integration outside the
integration, which means that I
can then write the
result as being
an exchange of the order
of the Poisson bracket
and the integration.
So I would essentially have the
integration only appear here,
which is the same
thing as Hs and rho s.
This should be rho s.
This is the definition of rho s,
which is the same thing as rho.
OK.
What does it mean physically?
So it's actually much
easier to tell you
what it means physically
than to do the math.
So what we saw was
happening was that if I
have a Hamiltonian that
describes N particles, then
for that Hamiltonian,
the corresponding density
satisfies this
Liouville equation.
D rho by dt is HN rho.
And this was a consequence of
this divergence-less character
of the flow that we
have in this space,
that the equations that
we write down over here
for p dot and q
dot in terms of H
had this character that
the divergence was 0.
OK?
Now, this is true if I have
any number of particles.
So if I focus simply
on s of the particles,
and they are governed
by this Hamiltonian,
and I don't have anything
else in the universe,
as far as this
Hamiltonian is concerned,
I should have the analog
of a Liouville equation.
So the term that I have obtained
over there from this first term
is simply stating
that d rho s by dt,
if there was no other
interaction with anybody else,
would simply satisfy the
corresponding Liouville
equation for s particles.
And because of that, we
also expect and anticipate--
and I'll show that
mathematically--
that the next term
in the series,
that is the Poisson bracket
of N minus s and rho,
should be 0, because as
far as this s particles
that I'm focusing on
and how they evolve,
they really don't care about
what all the other particles
are doing if they
are not [INAUDIBLE].
So anything interesting
should ultimately
come from this third term.
But let's actually go and do the
calculation for the second term
to show that this anticipation
that the answer should be 0
does hold up and why.
So for the second term, I need
to calculate a similar Poisson
bracket, except that
this second Poisson
bracket involves H of N minus s.
And H of N minus s, when
I put in the full sum,
will only get contribution from
terms that start from s plus 1.
So the same way that
that started from N,
this contribution starts
from s plus 1 to N.
And actually, I can just write
the whole thing as above, d
rho by d qj dotted by d HN minus
s by dpj, plus d rho by-- no,
this is the rho. d rho by d pj
dotted by dHN minus s by dqj.
So now I have a totally
different situation
from the previous case,
because the previous case,
the derivatives were over
things I was not integrating.
I could take outside
the integral.
Now all of the
derivatives involve things
that I'm integrating over.
Now, when that happens, then
you do integration by parts.
So what you do is
you take rho outside
and let the derivative
act on everything else.
OK?
So what do we end up with if
we do integration by parts?
I will get surface terms.
Surface terms are essentially
rho-evaluated when
the coordinates are at
infinity or at the edge
of your space, where rho is 0.
So there is no surface term.
There is an overall
change in sign,
so I will get a product
i running from s plus 1
to N, dVi.
Now the rho comes outside.
And the derivative acts on
everything that is left.
So the first term will
give me a second derivative
of HN minus s, with respect
to p, with respect to q.
And the second term will be
essentially the opposite way
of doing the derivative.
And these two are,
of course, the same.
And the answer is 0.
OK?
So we do expect that
the evolution of all
the other particles
should not affect
the subset that
we are looking at.
And that's worn out also.
So the only thing
that potentially
will be relevant and exciting
is the last term, number c.
So let's take a look at that.
So here, I have to do an
integration over variables
that I am not interested.
And then I need now,
however, to do a full Poisson
bracket of a whole
bunch of terms,
because now the terms
that I'm looking at
have coordinates from both sets.
So I have to be a
little bit careful.
So let me just make sure that
I follow the notes that I
have here and don't
make mistakes.
OK.
So this H prime
involves two sums.
So I will write the first
sum, N running from 1 to s.
And then I have the second
sum, j running from s
plus 1 to N. What do I need?
I need the-- OK.
Let's do it the following way.
So what I have to do
for the Poisson bracket
is a sum that involves
all coordinates.
So let's just write
this whole expression.
But first, for
coordinates 1 through s.
So I have a sum N
running from 1 to s.
And then I will
write the term that
corresponds to
coordinates s plus 1 to m.
For the first set of
coordinates, what do I have?
I have d rho by dqn.
And then I have
d H prime by dpn.
So I didn't write
H prime explicitly.
I'm just breaking
the sum over here.
And then I have sum j
running from s plus 1 to N,
d rho by dqj times
d H prime by dpj.
And again, my H prime
is this entity over here
that [? copies ?]
coordinates from both sets.
OK.
First thing is I claim that one
of these two sets of sums is 0.
You tell me which.
AUDIENCE: The first.
PROFESSOR: Why first?
AUDIENCE: Because H prime is
independent of p [? dot. ?]
PROFESSOR: That's true.
OK.
That's very good.
And then it sort of brings
up a very important question,
which is, I forgot to
write two more terms.
[LAUGHTER]
Running to s of d rho by dpn,
d H prime by dqn minus sum j
s plus 1 to N of d rho by
dpj dot dH prime by dqj.
So indeed, both answers
now were correct.
Somebody said that
the first term
is a 0, because H prime
does not depend on pn.
And somebody over here
said that this term is 0.
And maybe they can explain why.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Same
reason as up here.
That is, I can do
integration by parts.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: To get rid of this
term plus this term together.
So it's actually
by itself is not 0.
But if I do
integration by parts,
I will have-- actually,
even by itself, it is 0,
because I would have d
by dqj, d by pj, H prime.
And H prime, you cannot
have a double derivative pj.
So each one of them,
actually, by itself is 0.
But in general, they would
also cancel each other
through their single process.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you have the sign
of [? dH ?] of [? H prime? ?]
PROFESSOR: Did I have
the sign incorrect?
Yes.
Because for some
reason or other,
I keep reading from here, which
is rho and H. So let's do this.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Excuse me.
PROFESSOR: Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
Yes, it is different.
Yes.
So what I said, if I had
a more general Hamiltonian
that also depended
on momentum, then
this term would, by itself
not 0, but would cancel,
be the corresponding
term from here.
But the way that I
have for H prime,
indeed, each term by
itself would be 0.
OK.
So hopefully-- then
what do we have?
So actually, let's keep the
sign correct and do this,
because I need this right
sign for the one term
that is preserved.
So what does that say?
It is a sum, n
running from 1 to s.
OK?
I have d H prime by dqn.
And I have this integration.
I have the integration i running
from s plus 1 to N dV of i.
I have d rho by
dpn dot producted
with d H prime by dqN.
d H prime by dqn I can
calculate from here,
is a sum over terms j
running from s plus 1
to N of V of qn minus qj.
All right.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why aren't you
differentiating [? me ?]
if you're
differentiating H prime?
PROFESSOR: d by dqj.
All right?
AUDIENCE: Where is the qn?
PROFESSOR: d by dqn.
Thank you.
Right.
Because always, pn of
qn would go together.
Thank you.
OK.
All right.
So we have to slog
through these derivations.
And then I'll give you
the physical meaning.
So I can rearrange this.
Let's see what's happening here.
I have here a sum
over particles that
are not listed on
the left-hand side.
So when I wrote
this d rho by dt,
I had listed coordinates
going from p1 through qs that
were s coordinates
that were listed.
If you like, you can think
of them as s particles.
Now, this sum involves
the remaining particles.
What is this?
Up to a sign.
This is the force that
is exerted by particle j
from the list of
particles that I'm not
interested on one of the
particles on the list
that I am interested.
OK?
Now, I expect that at the end
of the day, all of the particles
that I am not interested
I can treat equivalently,
like everything
that we had before,
like how I got this factor
of N or N minus 1 over there.
I expect that all of these will
give me the same result, which
is proportional to the number
of these particles, which
is N minus s.
OK?
And then I can focus on just
one of the terms in this sum.
Let's say the term
that corresponds to j,
being s plus 1.
Now, having done that,
I have to be careful.
I can do separately
the integration
over the volume of this one
coordinate that I'm keeping,
V of s plus 1.
And what do I have here?
I have the force that
exerted on particle number N
by the particle that
is labelled s plus 1.
And this force is dot
producted with a gradient
along the momentum in direction
of particle N of its density.
Actually, this is the
density of all particles.
This is the rho that
corresponds to the joint.
But I had here s
plus 1 integrations.
One of them I wrote
down explicitly.
All the others I do over here.
Of the density.
So basically, I change the
order of the derivative
and the integrations over
the variables not involved
in the remainder.
And the reason I
did that, of course,
is that then this
is my rho s plus 1.
OK?
So what we have at
the end of the day
is that if I take the time
variation of an s particle
density, I will get one
term that I expected,
which is if those s particles
were interacting only
with themselves, I would
write the Liouville equation
that would be
appropriate to them.
But because of the
collisions that I
can have with particles
that are not over here,
suddenly, the momenta that
I'm looking at could change.
And because of that, I
have a correction term here
that really describes
the collisions.
It says here that
these s particles
were following the
trajectory that
was governed by the
Hamiltonian that
was peculiar to the s particles.
But suddenly, one of them had
a collision with somebody else.
So which one of them?
Well, any one of them.
So I could get a contribution
from any one of the s particles
that is listed over here, having
a collision with somebody else.
How do I describe
the effect of that?
I have to do an integration over
where this new particle that I
am colliding with could be.
I have to specify both where the
particle is that I am colliding
with, as well as its momentum.
So that's this.
Then I need to know the
force that this particle is
exerting on me.
So that's the V of qs plus
1 minus qN divided by dqN.
This is the force that is
exerted by this particle
that I don't see on myself.
Then I have to multiply this,
or a dot product of this,
with d by dpN, because what
happens in the process,
because of this force, the
momentum of the N particle
is changing.
The variation of
that is captured
through looking at
the density that
has all of these particles in
addition to this new particle
that I am colliding with.
But, of course, I am not really
interested in the coordinate
of this new particle,
so I integrate over it.
There are N minus
s such particles.
So I really have to put
a factor of N minus s
here for all of
potential collisions.
And so that's the equation.
Again, it is more common,
rather than to write
the equation for rho, to
write the equation for f.
And the f's and the
rhos where simply
related by these factors of
N factorial over N minus 1
s factorial.
And the outcome of that
is that the equation for f
simply does not have this
additional factor of N minus s,
because that disappears
in the ratio of rho
of s plus 1 and rho s.
And it becomes a sum over
N running from 1 to s.
Integral over coordinates and
momenta of a particle s plus 1.
The force exerted
by particle s plus 1
on particle N used to vary the
momentum of the N particle.
And the whole thing would depend
on the density that includes,
in addition to the s
particles that I had before,
the new particle that
I am colliding with.
OK?
So there is a set
of equations that
relates the different densities
and how they evolve in time.
The evolution of f1, which is
the thing that I am interested,
will have, on the
right-hand side,
something that involves f2.
The evolution of
f2 will involve f3.
And this whole thing is
called a BBGKY hierarchy,
after people whose names
I have in the notes.
[SOFT LAUGHTER]
But again, what have
we learned beyond what
we had in the original case?
And originally,
we had an equation
that was governing a function
in 6N-dimensional space, which
we really don't need.
So we tried our
best to avoid that.
We said that all of the physics
is in one particle, maybe
two particle densities.
Let's calculate the evolution
of one-particle and two-particle
densities.
Maybe they will tell us about
this non-equilibrium situation
that we set up.
But we see that the time
evolution of the first particle
density requires
two-particle density.
Two-particle density requires
three-particle densities.
So we sort of made this
ladder, which ultimately will
[? terminate ?] at the
Nth particle densities.
And so we have not
really gained much.
So we have to now look at these
equations a little bit more
and try to inject more physics.
So let's write down the
first two terms explicitly.
So what I will do is I will
take this Poisson bracket of H
and f, to the left-hand
side, and use the Hamiltonian
that we have over here
to write the terms.
So the equation that we
have for f1-- and I'm
going to write it as a
whole bunch of derivatives
acting on f1.
f1 is a function of p1 q1 t.
And essentially, what
Liouville's theorem
says is that as you move
along the trajectory,
the total derivative is
0, because the expansion
of the flows is incompressible.
So what does that mean?
It means that d by dt, which
is this argument, plus q1 dot
times d by dq1 plus
p1 dot by d by dp1.
So here, I should write
p1 dot and q1 dot.
In the absence of
everything else is 0.
Then, of course, for q1
dot, we use the momentum
that we would get out of this.
q1 dot is momentum
divided by mass.
So that's the velocity.
And p1 dot, changing
momentum, is
the force, is minus dH by dq1.
So this is minus d of this
one particle potential divided
by dq1 dotted by [? h ?] p1.
So if you were asked to think
about one particle in a box,
then you know its
equation of motion.
If you have many,
many realizations
of that particle in a box,
you can construct a density.
Each one of the elements
of the trajectory,
you know how they
evolve according
to [? Newton's ?] equation.
And you can see how the
density would evolve.
It would evolve
according to this.
I would have said, equal to 0.
But I can't set it to 0 if I'm
really thinking about a gas,
because my particle
can come and collide
with a second
particle in the gas.
The second particle
can be anywhere.
And what it will do is that
it will exert a force, which
would be like this,
on particle one.
And this force will
change the momentum.
So my variation of
the momentum will not
come only from the
external force,
but also from the
force that is coming
from some other
particle in the medium.
So that's where
this d by dp really
gets not only the
external force but also
the force from somebody else.
But then I need to know
where this other particle is,
given that I know where
my first particle is.
So I have to include here a
two-particle density which
depends on p1 as
well as q2 at time t.
OK.
Fine.
Now you say, OK, let's write
down-- I need to know f2.
Let's write down
the equation for f2.
So I will write it more rapidly.
I have p1 over m, d by dq1.
I have p2 over m, d by dq2.
I will have dU by dq1, d by dp1.
I will have dU by dq2, d by dp2.
I will have also a term from
the collision between q1 and q2.
And once it will change the
momentum of the first particle,
but it will change the
momentum of the second particle
in the opposite direction.
So I will put the
two of them together.
So this is all of the terms that
I would get from H2, Poisson
bracket with density acting
on the two-particle density.
And the answer would be
0 if the two particles
were the only thing in the box.
But there's also
other particles.
So there can be
interactions and collisions
with a third particle.
And for that, I
would need to know,
let's actually try
to simplify notation.
This is the force that is
exerted from two to one.
So I will have here the
force from three to one
dotted by d by dp1.
Right.
And the force that is
exerted from three to two
dotted by d by dp2 acting on
a three-particle density that
involves everything up to three.
And now let's write
the third one.
[LAUGHTER]
So that, I will leave
to next lecture.
But anyway, so this
is the structure.
Now, this is the
point at which we
would like to inject some
physics into the problem.
So what we are going to do is to
estimate the various terms that
are appearing in this
equation to see whether there
is some approximation
that we can make
to make the equations more
treatable and handle-able.
All right?
So let's try to look
at the case of a gas--
let's say the gas in this room.
A typical thing
that is happening
in the particles of
the gas in this room
is that they are zipping around.
Their velocity is of
the order-- again,
just order of magnitude,
hundreds of meters per second.
OK?
So we are going to, again,
be very sort of limited
in what we are
trying to describe.
There is this experiment.
Gas expands into a chamber.
In room temperature, typical
velocities are of this order.
Now we are going to
use that to estimate
the magnitude of the
various terms that
are appearing in this equation.
Now, the whole thing
about this equation
is variation with time.
So the entity that
we are looking
at in all of these
brackets is this d by dt,
which means that the various
terms in this differential
equation, apart
from d by dt, have
to have dimensions
of inverse time.
So we are going to
try to characterize
what those inverse times are.
So what are the typical
magnitudes of various terms?
If I look at the
first equation, I
said what that first
equation describes.
That first equation describes
for you a particle in a box.
We've forgotten about
everything else.
So if I have a
particle in a box,
what is the characteristic time?
It has to be set by the
size of the box, given
that I am moving
with that velocity.
So there is a
timescale that I would
call extrinsic in the
sense that it is not really
a property of the gas.
It will be different if
I make the box bigger.
There's a timescale
over which I would
go from one side of the box
to another side of the box.
So this is kind of
a timescale that
is related to the term
that knows something
about the box, which
is dU by dq, d by dp.
I would say that if I were to
assign some typical magnitude
to this type of
term, I would say
that it is related to having
to traverse a distance that
is of the order of
the size of the box,
given the velocity
that I have specified.
This is an inverse timescale.
Right?
And let's sort of
imagine that I have an--
and I will call this
timescale 1 over tau U,
because it is sort of
determined by my external U.
Let's say we have
a typical size that
is of the order of millimeter.
If I make it larger,
it will be larger.
So actually, let's say we
have 10 to the minus 3 meters.
Actually, let's make it bigger.
Let's make it of the order
of 10 to the minus 1 meter.
Kind of reasonable-sized box.
Then you would say
that this 1 over tau c
is of the order of 10 to the 2
divided by 10 to the minus 1,
which is of the order of 1,000.
Basically, it
takes a millisecond
to traverse a box
that is a fraction
of a meter with
these velocities.
OK?
You say fine.
That is the kind
of timescale that I
have in the first equation
that I have in my hierarchy.
And that kind of
term is certainly
also present in the second
equation for the hierarchy.
If I have two particles,
maybe these two particles
are orbiting each
other, et cetera.
Still, their center of
mass would move, typically,
with this velocity.
And it would take
this amount of time
to go across the
size of the box.
But there is another
timescale inside there
that I would call intrinsic,
which involves dV/dq, d by dp.
Now, if I was to see what
the characteristic magnitude
of this term is, it would
have to be V divided
by a lens scale that
characterizes the potential.
And the potential, let's
say, is of the order
of atomic size or
molecular size.
Let's call it d.
So this is an atomic
size-- or molecular size.
More correctly, really, it's
the range of the interaction
that you have between particles.
And typical values of
these [? numbers ?]
are of the order of 10
angstroms, or angstroms,
or whatever.
Let's say 10 to the
minus 10 meters.
Sorry.
The first one I would
like to call tau U.
This second time,
that I will call
1 over tau c for collisions,
is going to be the ratio of 10
to the 2 to 10 to the minus 10.
It's of the order of 10
to the 12 in both seconds.
OK?
So you can see that this term is
much, much larger in magnitude
than the term that was
governing the first equation.
OK?
And roughly, what you
expect in a situation
such as this-- let's imagine,
rather than shooting particles
from here, you are
shooting bullets.
And then the bullets
would come and basically
have some kind of
trajectory, et cetera.
The characteristic time
for a single one of them
would be basically
something that
is related to the
size of the box.
How long does it take a bullet
to go over the size of the box?
But if two of these
bullets happen
to come together and
collide, then there's
a very short period
of time over which
they would go in
different directions.
And the momenta
would get displaced
from what they were before.
And that timescale is
of the order of this.
But in the situation
that I set up,
this particular
time is too rapid.
There is another
more important time,
which is, how long
do I have to wait
for two of these particles,
or two of these bullets,
to come and hit each other?
So it's not the duration of the
collision that is irrelevant,
but how long it would be for
me to find another particle
to collide with.
And actually, that is what
is governed by the terms
that I have on the other side.
Because the terms on the
other side, what they say is I
have to find another particle.
So if I look at the terms that
I have on the right-hand side
and try to construct
a characteristic time
out of them, I have to compare
the probability that I will
have, or the density that
I will have for s plus 1,
integrated over some
volume, over which
the force between these
particles is non-zero.
And then in order to
construct a timescale for it,
I know that the d by dt on
the left-hand side acts on fs.
On the right-hand
side, I have fs plus 1.
So again, just if I want
to construct dimensionally,
it's a ratio that
involves s plus 1 to s.
OK?
So I have to do an
additional integration
over a volume in phase space
over which two particles can
have substantial interactions.
Because that's where
this [? dv ?] by dq
would be non-zero, provided
that there is a density for s
plus 1 particle
compared to s particles.
If you think about
it, that means
that I have to look
at the typical density
or particles times d cubed for
these additional operations
multiplied by this collision
time that I had before.
OK?
And this whole thing I will
call 1 over tau collision.
And another way of getting
the same result is as follows.
This is typically how you get
collision times by pictorially.
You say that I have something
that can interact over
some characteristic size d.
It moves in space
with velocity v
so that if I wait a time
that I will call tau,
within that time,
I'm essentially
sweeping a volume of space that
has volume d squared v tau.
So my cross section, if my
dimension is d, is d squared.
I sweep in the other
direction by [? aman ?] d tau.
And how many particles
will I encounter?
Well, if I know
the density, which
is the number of
particles per unit volume,
I have to multiply this by n.
So how far do I have
to go until I hit 1?
I'll call that tau x.
Then my formula
for tau x would be
1 over nvd squared, which
is exactly what I have here.
1 over tau x is
nd squared v. OK?
So in order to compare
the terms that I
have on the right-hand
side with the terms
on the left-hand
side, I notice that I
need to know something
about nd cubed.
So nd cubed tells you
if I have a particle
here and this particle has
a range of interactions
that I call d, how many
other particles fall
within that range
of interaction?
Now, for the gas in this room,
the range of the interaction
is of the order of the
size of the molecule.
It is very small.
And the distance between
molecules in this room
is far apart.
And indeed, you can estimate
that for gas, nd cubed
has to be of the order
of 10 to the minus 4.
And how do I know that?
Because if I were to take all of
the gas particles in this room
and put them together so
that they are touching,
then I would have a liquid.
And the density of,
say, typical liquid
is of the order of 10,000 times
larger than the density of air.
So basically, it has to
be a number of this order.
OK?
So fine.
Let's look at our equations.
So what I find is that
in this equation for f2,
on the left-hand
side, I have a term
that has magnitude that is
very large-- 1 over tau c.
Whereas the term on
the right-hand side,
in terms of magnitude,
is something like this.
And in fact, this will be
true for every equation
in the hierarchy.
So maybe if I am in the
limit where nd cubed is much,
much less than 1-- such as
the gas in this room, which
is called the dilute limit-- I
can ignore the right-hand side.
I can set the
right-hand side to 0.
OK?
Now, I can't do that
for the first equation,
because the first
equation is really
the only equation in the
hierarchy that does not
have the collision term
on the left-hand side.
Right?
And so for the first equation,
I really need to keep that.
And actually, it goes
back to all of the story
that we've had over here.
Remember that we said
this rho equilibrium has
to be a function of H
and conserved quantities.
Suppose I go to my
Hamiltonian and I
ignore all of these
interactions, which
is what I would
have done if I just
look at the first term over
here and set the collision
term on the
right-hand side to 0.
What would happen then?
Then clearly, for each
one of the particles,
I have-- let's say it's energy
is going to be conserved.
Maybe the magnitude
of its momentum
is going to be conserved in
the appropriate geometry.
And so there will
be a huge number
of individual
conserved quantities
that I would have
to put over there.
Indeed, if I sort of
go back to the picture
that I was drawing over
here, if I ignore collisions
between the particles, then
the bullets that I send
will always be following
a trajectory such as this
forever, because momentum
will be conserved.
You will always-- I mean,
except up to reflection.
And say the
magnitude of velocity
would be always
following the same thing.
OK?
So however, if there is
a collision between two
of the particles-- so the
particles that come in here,
they have different velocities,
they will hit each other.
The moment they hit
each other, they
go off different directions.
And after a certain
number of hits,
then I will lose all
of the regularity
of what I had in the beginning.
And so essentially,
this second term
on the right-hand
with the collisions
is the thing that
is necessary for me
to ensure that my gas does come
to equilibrium in the sense
that their momenta get
distributed and reversed.
I really need to
keep track of that.
And also, you can see that
the timescales for which
this kind of
equilibration takes place
has to do with this
collision time.
But as far as this term
is concerned, for the gas
or for that system of bullets,
it doesn't really matter.
Because for this term
to have been important,
it would have been
necessary for something
interesting to physically occur
should three particles come
together simultaneously.
And if I complete
the-- say that never
in the history of this
system three particles will
come together, they do
come together in reality.
It's not that big a difference.
It's only a factor of
10 to the 4 difference
between the right-hand side
and the left-hand side.
But still, even if
they didn't, there
was nothing about
equilibration of the gas that
would be missed by this.
So it's a perfectly reasonable
approximation and assumption,
therefore, for us
to drop this term.
And we'll see that although
that is physically motivated,
it actually doesn't resolve
this question of irreversibility
yet, because that's also
potentially a system
that you could set up.
You just eliminate all of
the three-body interactions
from the problem.
Still, you could have
a very reversible set
of conditions and
deterministic process
that you could reverse in time.
But still, it's
sort of allows us
to have something that
is more manageable,
which is what we will
be looking at next.
Before I go to what
is next, I also
mentioned that there is
one other limit where
one can do things,
which is when,
within the range of
interaction of one particle,
there are many other particles.
So you are in the dense limit,
nd cubed greater than 1.
This does not happen for a
liquid, because for a liquid,
the range does not allow many
particles to come within it.
But it happens
for a plasma where
you have long-range
Coulomb interaction.
And within the range
of Coulomb interaction,
you could have many
other interactions.
And so that limit you will
explore in the problem set
leads to a different description
of approach to equilibrium.
It's called the Vlasov equation.
What we are going to proceed
with now will lead to something
else, which is called--
in the dilute limit,
it will get the
Boltzmann equation.
OK?
So let's see what we have.
So currently, we
achieved something.
We want to describe
properties of a few particles
in the system-- densities
that describe only,
say, one particle by itself
if one was not enough.
But I can terminate
the equations.
And with one-particle density
and two-particle density,
I should have an
appropriate description
of how the system evolves.
Let's think about
it one more time.
So what is happening here?
There is the
one-particle description
that tells you how the
density for one particle,
or an ensemble, the probability
for one particle, its position
and momentum evolves.
But it requires
knowledge of what
would happen with a
second particle present.
But the equations that we
have for the density that
involves two particles is
simply a description of things
that you would do if you had
deterministic trajectories.
There is nothing else
on the right-hand side.
So basically, all you
need to do is in order
to determine this, is to have
full knowledge of what happens
if two particles come
together, collide together, go
away, all kinds of things.
So if you have those
trajectories for two particles,
you can, in principle,
build this density.
It's still not an easy task.
But in principle,
one could do that.
And so this is the
description of f2.
And we expect f2 to
describe processes
in which, over a very
rapid timescale, say,
momenta gets shifted from one
direction to another direction.
But then there is something
about the overall behavior that
should follow, more or less, f1.
Again, what do I mean?
What I mean is the following,
that if I open this box,
there is what you would observe.
The density would kind
of gush through here.
And so you can
have a description
for how the density, let's
say in coordinate space,
would be evolving as
a function of time.
If I ask how does the
two-particle prescription
evolve, well, the two-particle
prescription, part of it
is what's the
probability that I have
a particle here and
a particle there?
And if the two particles, if
the separations are far apart,
you would be justified to
say that that is roughly
the product of the probabilities
that I have something here
and something there.
When you become very close
to each other, however,
over the range of
interactions and collisions,
that will have to be modified,
because at those descriptions
from here, you
would have to worry
about the collisions, and the
exchange of momenta, et cetera.
So in that sense, part of f2
is simply following f1 slowly.
And part of f1 captures all of
the collisions that you have.
In fact, that part of f2 that
captures in the collisions,
we would like to simplify
as much as possible.
And that's the next
task that we do.
So what I need to do
is to somehow express
the f2 that appears
in the first equation
while solving this equation
that is the second one.
I will write the answer
that we will eventually
deal with and
explain it next time.
So the ultimate result would
be that the left-hand side,
we will have the terms
that we have currently.
f1.
On the right-hand
side, what we find
is that I need to
integrate over all momenta
of a second particle
and something that
is like a distance to the
target-- one term that
is the flux of
incoming particles.
And then we would have f2
after collision minus f2
before collision.
And this is really
the Boltzmann equation
after one more approximation,
where we replace f2 with f1.
f1.
But what all of that
means symbolically
and what it is we'll have
to explain next time.